today's question comes from connie in
pennsylvania i've been at my job now for
three years it's a job i enjoy
but every time i try to get a promotion
i keep getting passed up i'm at a loss
and it feels as if my job doesn't care
how hard i work
many years ago i went to school for
massage therapy but i never pursued it
i'm not sure if i'm even interested in
pursuing it because it's been so long
do you have any suggestions on next
steps for me well we've got two
two questions here within the question
the first question is
if i had you on the air i'd want to know
if you sat down with leadership
and asked them for some real good 360
degree feedback from your peers
from them as to why you're not moving up
the ladder what can you do better
and and really dive in and find out is
it a healthy culture like ramsay
solutions where
if you do a good job you know your role
and you accept your role and you
maximize it you're going to get an
opportunity to move up here
if you're not we're going to tell you
that's right and then you don't know
what to do
so you need to get i'd like to know more
about what you do know
and then what you're doing about now the
second half of the question you could be
doing the wrong thing and working real
hard at it that's exactly we've talked
about hard work hard work is a good
thing
but it's not the only thing that's
exactly hard effective
work that creates results and doesn't
piss everybody in the proximity off in
the process
that's right that's a that's a promotal
promotable event that's exactly you're
making everybody mad in the process
or you're working hard on the wrong
thing or you're working really hard but
there's no results from it because
you're doing it poorly
even though you've got a lot of sweat
there's nothing happening here well you
can sweat and not score touchdowns
that's right now here's the other thing
you could also be working really hard
they can notice and appreciate the hard
work but you might be putting yourself
up for a promotion that you don't have
the talent to actually pull off
sometimes our eyes can be bigger than
our belly you know the idea of going
going for something that you may not be
a good fit for and so that's why we
teach on the ken coleman show
the sweet spot where you use what you do
best talent to do
work that you love to do to produce a
result that matters so we don't know
here
i think talking through with leadership
is the big issue that's where you got to
start yeah you got to know where you
stand
and why you stand now the second half of
the question is i i pursued massage
therapy
but excuse me i went to massage therapy
school i did not pursue it how do i know
ken if it's something i should do and
this is why i wrote the book the
proximity principle which says
in order to do what you want to do get
around people that are doing it and in
places where it is happening
now in this case you use the proximity
principle
to validate whether or not you really
want to do it i i call it
clarify and verify so you're going to be
talking to successful
what i mean by that is they've been
employed a while and they
enjoy massage therapy you got to talk to
those people and it's like doing a
college or high school term paper
ask everything about the day favorite
parts of the day the part of the day
they don't like
how they got there what do they do to
stay active
and thrive in the role and when you get
that
uh information dave that's the clarify
your brain processes it and then your
heart's either going to go ding ding
ding
or and that's what you have to do you've
got to really talk to somebody
multiple people and and learn about the
work
and your heart and head will combine in
that situation
and you're going to know whether or not
you should pursue that i'll give you an
example i
have a friend that um hears me i mean
always when i get a call or someone in
the nursing field
i'm always bragging on them because it's
a wonderful field in terms of
opportunity
you can work as much you want to work
you make good money uh there's always a
shortage
and so it's a wonderful field to go into
in terms of that uh
and uh you know she was thinking to go
to nursing school in her 30s
and i said well you know ken coleman
says go shadow for the day just go be
like a college intern
and go hang out with a nurse all day
long
and this was pre pandemic but she goes
and hang out
she goes it's gross i didn't want to do
that
but all the idea of being a nurse and
being helpful and kind and
and uh you know healer and all that kind
of thing was very appealing but
when she saw what it actually the
day-to-day job involved
it was gross that's gross i won't do
that that's right and i was like well it
was a
one day well spent rather than going to
nursing school and then discovering that
so true one day clarify and verify and
for those people who want to kind of
kick the tires on that talent passion
mission those three gifts
from your creator that'll help you find
your sweet spot dave we have a free
resource at kencolma.com called the
career clarity guide
and it's free and it'll walk them
through step by step
what i just kind of quickly went through
and you get a lot of clarity
as to some potential jobs in your sweet
spot because there are multiple
multiple career paths and then you do
what we just described and you'd be
surprised how quickly
you can get clear and then you're
confident to step out
you could be real clear on what your
mother wants you to do but that's not
helpful
boy isn't that the truth you could be
real clear on what makes a lot of money
but that's not helpful what you need to
be clear on
is what you're designed to do when
you're here ken coleman.com it's a free
resource and it's called again what the
career clarity guide
career clarity great guy those of you on
youtube are looking right at it okay